hello everybody
this is my first video since i got back
from europe and i had covid and i've
been in self-isolation i thought i would
be making videos
during my isolation but it turns out my
brain was so much in so much fog that it
was just impossible to make videos and
so i'm happy to be making videos again
hopefully my strength will hold up and i
won't get too tired
so i wanted for the past uh month or so
or i guess a few months i've been making
more videos on scripture i've been doing
some interpretation of christ's parables
of the the sermon on the mount
and
just trying to help people see the
pattern
the symbolic pattern in scripture but
what i wanted with to do with you today
is to look at a short text in saint from
the syrians hymns on paradise i've told
you guys many times about many times
about this book if you haven't read it
and you're watching my videos you really
need to read synephrine's hymns on
paradise i'm going to read three stanzas
from the hymns and
we're going to revisit some of the
videos that i did and look at another
story of christ and hopefully it'll help
you see
how it is that i draw all of this
together and
why it is that i see the patterns that i
see
it's a lot of it is using san ephraim as
a guide to interpret scripture
of course he's not doing it arbitrarily
he himself
as the guide is pulling together all
these threads in scripture into very
short and condensed stanzas and so
it's sometimes difficult because it can
take some time to unpack them but
hopefully you'll follow me along and
it'll give you a few secret keys to the
interpretation of scripture
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
and so the uh the stanzas that i'm
reading i'm gonna read three are from
page 78 of the uh the the saint vladimir
seminary edition of the hymns on
paradise translated by sebastian brock
with a great introduction so sinephrus
starts he says with the eyes of my mind
i gazed upon paradise
the summit of every mountain is lower
than its summit
the crest of the flood reached only its
foothills
then it kissed with reverence beyond
turning back
to rise above and subdue the peak of
every hill and mountain
the foothills of paradise it kisses
while every summit it buffets
not that the ascent to paradise is
arduous because of its height
for those who inherit it
experience no toil there
with its beauty
it joyfully urges on those who ascend
amidst glorious rays it lies resplendent
all fragrant with its sense
magnificent clouds fashion the abodes
of those who are worthy of it
from their abodes the children of light
descend
they rejoiced in the midst of the world
where they have been persecuted
they dance on the sea's surface and do
not sink
for simon although a rock
did not sink
bless it is he who has seen
together with them
his beloved ones below in their bands of
disciples
and on high
in their bridal chambers so those are
the three stanzas that i wanted to read
to you now i could have kept reading i
could have read a little bit before a
little bit after and i would have found
as many nuggets of amazing
uh of amazing interpretation in terms of
paradise
now of course the first important part
is to notice the cosmic aspect of the
paradise that is he starts and he says
with the eye of my mind
this is very important because he is
already placing the relationship of
paradise
in relationship to the person with mind
or with noose or with you know the
highest aspect of human faculty and so
there's already a hierarchy being set up
in the structure of the text by even
saying that he gazes upon paradise not
with his physical eyes but with the eyes
of his mind
because there's something about paradise
which is impossible in terms of
quantitative
understanding
and so he places the summit of the
mountain of paradise higher than all the
summits of every other mountain
and then so he starts up high says the
the
the summit of every mountain is lower
than the summit of paradise
and then he says the crest of the flood
reached only its foothills the foothills
of paradise
kisses it with reverence before turning
back to rise above and subdue the
peak of every hill and mountain
now remember of course the image of
paradise the image of everything that i
drew or maybe the image the second one i
did with the arc of noah you'll notice
that i really draw in from this
interpretation that is the height of the
mountain and then at the bottom of the
mountain you have the waters but here
it's very interesting because you notice
that in reference to paradise
the relationship between paradise and
the waters is something like a romantic
relationship where the waters kiss
the feet of paradise
but when the waters act on that which is
below paradise it buffets the summits
and so even the chaos of the lower
waters in relationship to paradise have
a relationship with his which is not
threatening which is something like the
the relationship between a man and a
woman which is uh which is very
important because you'll notice other
allusions to that sexual relationship in
the rest of the three stanzas now the
second stanza con continues this
this relationship of how that which is
below and that which is above
has
doesn't necessarily have a relationship
of austili but that that which is above
the hierarchy in that which is below the
hierarchy is really can be a
relationship of joy and of discovery uh
and so he says that the ascent to
paradise
is not arduous because of its height
for those who inherit it
they experience no toil there with its
beauty it joyfully urges on those who
ascend
amid the glorious rays it lies
resplendent all fragrant with its sense
magnificent clouds fashioned the abode
of those who are worthy of it and so
this going up the mountain he shows how
obviously you know that this is what
happened as you go up a mountain you
come closer to bathing in light let's
say and so as you he goes up the
mountain he says that those that inherit
the mountain in paradise
receive it as more light as you go up
and then the houses which are at the
summit of the mountain are fashioned by
clouds that is they're more subtle
they're not as
material in the way that we understand
it they're not as heavy they don't
they're they are more subtle bodies you
could say um you know and so this is
also related to the fact that saint
ephreme says that he views paradise
through the eye of the mind so just like
thoughts
are
have more subtle bodies that is you can
have intuitions and then thoughts and
those thoughts are more subtle there's
something like cloud let's say that form
houses for these pure intuitions in the
same way the houses which are at the
summit of paradise paradise are
fashioned by more subtle bodies um
but even all the way to the bottom of
the mountain like i said the the the
relationship is not one of uh
of contradiction or one you know of
hostility but even the waters at the
bottom of the mountain which in the body
would be something like the the uh
be something like the the physical body
you know the or the desires or whatever
that is that's at more at the lower
parts of the of the human psyche or the
human body then those nonetheless uh
have a relationship can have a
relationship which is closer to the
lover's relationship and so the third
the third sansa is where most of the
amazing meaning is
so he says from their abodes the
children of light descend
they rejoice in the midst of the world
where they have been persecuted and so
for them even the world of hostility
is
because they are coming down from the
summit of the mountain of paradise
persecution to them is actually joy
it is actually not hostility it is
transformed into joy because they get
their life their light from that which
is above and they don't focus they're
not attentive or they don't base their
life their light and their joy on that
which comes from below the thorns the
the waves all of this stuff which can be
dangerous to them it is joy they dance
on the sea surface and do not sink
for simon although a rock did not sink
blessed is he who has seen together with
them his beloved ones below in their
hands in their bands of disciples and on
high in their bridal chambers
i'm gonna look at this idea of coming
down the mountain and dancing on the sea
a little just a little later what i want
to look at it first is the basic
structure of talking about blessed he is
he who has seen
together with that with them
his beloved ones below in their bands of
disciple
and on high in their bridal chambers so
here you have a relationship of quantity
to quality and so you have the idea of
this band of disciples the band the band
of disciples which are below the
mountain
and the the the
highest aspect let's say of a
relationship which is something like the
closeness this this bridegroom bride
bridegroom relationship which is at the
height of the mountain
so if you think about some of the
stories that i've told you in the past
few years if you think about some of the
images that you find in the gospels
you'll notice for example when i talked
about the the parable of the vine
dressers in the parable of the vine
dressers it talks about calling people
to the wedding feast and calling people
to the wed to the wedding feast which is
in the king's castle and in the in my
interpretation i kept saying it's at the
top of a mountain and of course in the
text it doesn't say that it's at the top
of a mountain but as you start to notice
the patterns of how scripture works
saying something like it's at the top of
the mountain can help you understand how
it participates in this pattern so you
can see how sin ephraim puts the bridal
chamber at the top of the mountain
because the bridal chamber is equivalent
to moses encountering god in the secret
place it's the equivalent of going into
the holy of holies we know that all of
these images of intimacy and going into
the secret place are related to going up
to the top of the mountain where the
earth and heaven meet and this is the
sexual relationship between heaven and
earth
and then down below is where you have
quantity and so you have the band of
disciples you have the body of christ
now think of images stories for example
like christ going up to the mount of
olives where he goes up alone to the
mount and then has an encounter where
he's consoled by an angel but then
leaves the disciple below and tells them
to remember tells them to stay awake but
they can't they fall asleep now remember
now again the story of moses who goes up
the mountain to meet and receive the law
of god and leaves the people below the
band of disciples the body of israel
below
and while they are below and and god
and and not god moses has has went to
encounter god they forget about moses
and then they fall into distraction just
like the disciples fought fell into
distraction at the bottom of the mount
of olives as christ was ascending but
he's saying it's also possible to have
both it's also possible in the
in the best world to to to be able to
have this loving encounter up in the
highest place of the bridal chamber and
the intimacy of the bridal chamber and
also rejoice in the quantity of the band
of disciples of this communion of many
in which we are manifesting the body of
christ i wanted to go back at the to the
to the little part about coming down the
mountain and dancing on the sea and so
i mentioned this a few times in many
videos about how i really love this
image that said ephraim brings about but
what we need to do in order to
understand you know where is it that
saint ephreme gets this idea he gets it
from scripture he gets it exactly from
scripture so let's look at the text in
which christ walks on water and you'll
notice something that maybe you hadn't
noticed before
so the text where christ walks on water
is from we're using the the virgin the
gospel of saint matthew
chapter 14 starting at verse 22
immediately jesus made his disciples get
into the boat and go before him to the
other side while he sent the multitudes
away
and when he had sent the multitudes away
he went up the mountain by himself to
pray
now when evening came he was alone there
but the boat was now in the middle of
the sea tossed by the waves for the wind
was contrary
so notice now what has just been set up
for you what has just been set up for
you is the cosmic image
so christ
sends the multitudes away
like he did in the virgin of the of uh
of some of the parables that he tells
where he he sends the multitude away and
then he has only his disciples but then
he also tells his disciples to get into
a boat ahead of them then he goes up to
the mountain alone to pray now while he
is alone on the mountain the band of
disciples are now in the boat on the
flood
so the the image that you have is that
is the cosmic image it's of the garden
of paradise with with with that which is
above the meeting of heaven and earth
where christ is praying to his father at
the top of the mountain and the noah's
ark down on the flood in the waters
in a place where they feel as if they
have been forgotten by god and the waves
are tossing and turning and the chaos is
dangerous because in a certain manner
they the the
the spiritual principle the the highest
principle of their world has gone up in
order to encounter god and they have
forgotten him we could say something
like that now in the fourth watch of the
night jesus went to them walking on the
sea and when the disciples saw him
walking on the sea they were troubled
saying it is a ghost and they cried out
of fear
now remember the way that it was
presented by saint ephraim he said up on
the mountain the abodes are constructed
by clouds and so you can you can
understand that this is also what is
being referred to that is as christ
descends the mountain
he is more subtle you could say
because he has he has gone up to the
place where heaven and earth meet so
coming down the mountain he is
encountered as more subtle they see him
as a thought as a projection as a
phantasm as something which doesn't
fully have body
but immediately jesus spoke to them
saying be of good cheer
it is i do not be afraid
notice again what he's saying
he's saying what saint ephraim is saying
he's saying
rejoice
e on even on the flood
even in the place where you are
persecuted this is a place of joy
because i am coming to you from the top
of the mountain i'm bringing heaven down
to you and so this place which looks
like a place of chaos to you right now
is actually a place of joy it is
actually a place which is full and so
you do not need to be afraid
and peter answered him and said lord if
it is you
can ma command me to come to you on the
water
and so peter comes out and walks on the
water this is of course why synephrine
says that
there's a there's a there's a whole play
going on in this situation which is
christ is making even the rocks walk on
water he's bringing
he even peter who is supposed to be that
which sinks the bottom of the ocean if
he looks upon christ then that which is
meant to sink to the bottom can actually
rise up and dance upon the sea just like
christ has come down to walk on the
waters
and so he said come and when peter had
come down out of the boat he walked on
the water to go to jesus
but when he saw that the wind was
boisterous he was afraid and beginning
to sink he cried out
saying lord save me
and immediately jesus stretched out his
hand and caught him and said to him
o you of little faith why do you doubt
and when they got into the boat the wind
ceased
then those who were in the boat came and
worshiped him saying truly you are the
son of god.
and so of course there are many things
going on in this which are not
necessarily related to what saint ephram
said but maybe we can go over it a
little bit
that is it's interesting to notice for
example that when peter comes out of the
boat and he walks towards christ
what he notices we often think that he
notices the waves but it doesn't say
that in the text
he notices that the wind is boisterous
and is that which made him afraid
and and then that is what made it begin
to sink
and a good way to understand that in
terms of analogy is to understand how it
is usually our thoughts that make us
afraid it is actually the more subtle
things which make us afraid and is not
necessarily the world itself that is our
it's our thoughts about the world
which make us doubt it's our thoughts
about the world which make us not trust
god which make us or our thoughts about
ourselves which make us
be prideful or hate others and so the
danger is actually often in the middle
space between heaven and earth you could
say that is where
sin takes its root in the
more invisible aspect of yourself that
is your thoughts your
your ideas about how reality is um and
that's is actually what then makes them
sink in the water it's not that the
water isn't dangerous of course the
water is dangerous but it's only
dangerous to those who who get caught up
in this whirlwind of thoughts and and of
desires and all of this stuff um and so
and so saint peter sinks and then christ
immediately switches out his hand
catches him and says
why did you doubt
and so all of this then also becomes
about
doubt now the story of saint ephraim the
story that saint ephrem tells and the
story that we find here in scripture is
fractal it is a fractal story which
means that it applies cosmically to the
relationship between god between heaven
and earth manifestation in general but
it also applies to at a smaller level to
anything that you are ever involved with
so the way that this works you can use
any project that you're involved in and
you can understand the same problem now
think imagine you're working in a team
in order to
build a new a new product and so there's
something which is above there's a
leader who manifests who's supposed to
hold together
the reason why you're doing things he
holds the leadership together he holds
the
the the attention of the team
he directs the team and he also
is a placeholder for the reason why
you're doing things in the first place
now if that leader goes away or has or
is you know has to go somewhere else or
meets with the boss for a very long time
you can imagine the the team members now
don't know where to look and they can be
in danger
of starting their all their different
ideas of starting to conflict with each
other and not just that but maybe be
starting starting to focus more on their
own
rivalries their own little desires their
own idiosyncrasies
and forget the reason
why they are doing all of this in the
first place and this is when things
start to break down this is when the
chaos starts to happen and so in order
for you in order for the team to be able
to solve their problem they need to be
able to recognize once again
the reason why they're doing things and
that reason is something like a ghost in
the sense that the reason why you're
doing things together
is not in the things you're doing it's
above it it holds it stands above them
it has an invisible purpose
and looking to that invisible purpose
will rebind the world together will pull
the rock from out of the water pull the
earth the body from out of the water
just like christ is also actually in
this this uh this story christ is
actually
showing us an image of the actual
creation of the world he's actually
pulling the earth out of the waters like
you see at the beginning of genesis and
so this can be applied to a team but it
can also be applied to yourself as a
person with all your multiplicities of
thoughts and fears and of desires when
they forget the higher purposes of what
you're doing they can start to fragment
to break apart and then you can start to
sink but looking up above up above that
and remembering your purpose remembering
the reason why you do things can bring
you out of the waters
now of course
it's important to understand that this
only holds together if it culminates
into the transcendent if ultimately all
of these fractal patterns are held
together in a cosmic image of paradise
the the very same image that sent it
from the syrian tells about how the very
cosmos lays itself out and how it's held
together by this by this mountain of
meaning which moves up to the place
where we encounter god and so i wanted
to give you a little hint at some of the
ways in which i come to the
interpretations that i come i don't not
always explicit because as you notice it
can take quite a while to explain it but
hopefully this has been helpful to you
we'll encourage you to read the hands of
paradise and will also encourage you to
start thinking in that matter and start
understanding the manner in which
scripture pulls together these patterns
and so thanks for attention everybody
and hopefully we'll be making more
videos very soon
if you enjoy what we're doing here at
the symbolic world there are many ways
that you can get involved
there of course you can comment on these
videos you can share them to your
friends there's also a clips channel
which it breaks down some of my ideas
into shorter tidbits that you can also
go through and share with your friends
and comment on there is also a facebook
group where people discuss these
different ideas you can find all those
in the description and finally there's
also ways that you can support us
financially if you like what we're doing
you can buy some merchandise of
different designs of my own based on the
different ideas presented in the videos
but there's also ways to support us
directly you can go to the
symbolicworld.com
support and there you'll find different
ways to support the videos supporters of
the videos get
different opportunities to speak with me
one-on-one to ask questions in advance
the q a but all of everybody who
supports me gets an extra video a month
for patrons only and so i really
appreciate the support people have been
affording me and i hope that we can
continue doing this for a very long time